شكرا للزميل نايف اعزائي المشاهدين اسعد
الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مستمرون معكم في
تغطتنا للتطورات الدراماتيكيه في السودان
فبعد يوم من اعلان الجيش موافقته على
مبادره طرحتها منظمه الايجاد لحل الازمه
الراهنه اعلنت الخارجيه السودانيه اللام
مفاوضات بين الجيش والدعم السريع وان
السبيل الوحيد امام قوات حميته هو
الاستسلام ومع اغلاق الباب امام فرصي
تسويه الازمه عبر الحوار يبدو ان
المواجهات تشتد قبل ساعات على انتهاء
الهدنه المعلنه مراسل العربيه قال ان
الجيش ينفذ طلعات جويه جديده في الخرطوم
بينما يرد الدعم السريع بمضادات ارضيه اما
عن الوضع الصحي فحدث ولا حرج حيث دعا
الصليب الاحمر طرفي الصراع الى تسهيل عمل
المنظمات الانسانيه في وقت تتفاقم فيه
الازمه الانسانيه جراء المواجهات ما اجبر
اعدادا كبيره على النزوح
[موسيقى]
كما ترون انه مسجد بداد السوق المركزي
تدمر نهائي كل الدكاكين اللي في السوق ما
في دكان تجربه من
قوه الانفجار وجينا ما عندنا شيء ناكل
وانا نشربه
[موسيقى]
سيد البرهان والسيد حميد تبي
تعب الشعبي وللمعاناه التي عاناها الشعب
السوداني
طبعا الاخبار العاجله التي ترون على
الشاشه الخارجيه العراقيه وصول طائراطي
اجلاء قادمتين من السودان الى مطار بغداد
الدولي وايضا الخارجيه المصريه تقول منذ
قليل او تتحدث منذ قليل عن استقبال 16 الف
شخص من غير المصريين عبر المنافذ مع
السودان حتى الان
فيما خصم مبادره الايجاد بشان تسويه
الاوضاع في السودان بين طرفي الصراع نفت
الخارجيه السودانيه الانباء التي تتحدث عن
تفاوض الجيش مع الدعم السريع مشيره الى ان
لا صحه لقبول الجيش بالتفاوض مع الدعم
السريع وان لا خيار امام الدعم السريع سوى
الاستسلام كما ذكرنا واضافت الخارجيه
السودانيه ان قوات الدعم السريع مستمره في
خروقاتها للهدنه وتعديها على المدنيين
واستخدامهم دروعا بشريه
بيان الخارجيه السودانيه اتهم الدعم
السريع بالاعتداء على المستشفيات والمراكز
الصحيه وتعطيلي عملها
ومع استمرار المواجهات وترد الاوضاع
الامنيه في السودان وسط استمراري عمليه
الاجلاء تستمر حركات النزوح الداخلي الى
مناطق بعيده عن مواقع الاشتباكات او الى
دول الجوار حيث يستمر الابلاغ عن نزوح
المدنيين في ولايات الخرطوم والولايه
الشماليه والنيل الازرق وشمال كردفان
وشمال دارفور وغرب دارفور وجنوب دارفور
الى جانب التحركات عبر الحدود الى البلدان
المجاوره وقد حذرت الامم المتحده من ان
ربع مليون سوداني قد يكونون في طريقهم
للهرب برا الى الدول المجاوره ومن بين
الدول السبعه المجاوره للسودان فان اهم
التحركات وفق مفوضيه اللاجئين هي نحو تشاد
وجنوب السودان المفوضيه اوضحت ان الذين
شقوا طريقهم بانفسهم الى المناطق الحدوديه
مع تشاد يقدر عددهم بنحو 20 الفا كما انها
تتوقع عبور نحو 45 الف لاجئ سوداني جديد
الى جنوب السودان
والى مصر الجاره الشماليه ذكرت المفوضيه
ان لديها تقارير عن بدء نزوح بعض
النازحين الى مصر في حين اعلنت السلطات
المصريه ان الاف الاشخاص من مختلف
الجنسيات تمكنوا من الخروج من السودان الى
مصر عبر معبري قسطل وارجيل حيث يتجاوز
عددهم عشره الاف شخص
[موسيقى]
الازمه في السودان موجه هجره جديده صحيفه
تيليجراف البريطانيه تتوقع نزوح اعداد
مهوله من السكان وبالتالي زياده في عدد
المهاجرين غير النظامين
فبريطانيا وحدها قد تشهد لجوء اعداد كبيره
من السودانيين الامم المتحده تقول ان عددا
كبيرا من اللاجئين السودانيين فروا الى
بلدان المجاوره منذ بدء الازمه مع توقعات
بنزوح مئه الف سوداني الى تشاد ومئه
وسبعين الفا الى جنوب السودان بالاضافه
الى مصر وجمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى
بدورها تناشد الامم المتحده جميع الدول
بجوار السودان ابقاء حدودها مفتوحه امام
الذين يبحثون عن الاماني والحمايه
هذا واظاره مقاطع مصوره استعداد الحافلات
لعمليات النزوح من العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم هربا من الاقتتال الدائر
معي من الخرطوم لمزيد من المتابعه رئيس
تحرير صحيفه تيار عثمان مرغاني استاذ
عثمان اهلا وسهلا بك بدايه في تضارب في
المعلومات حول قبول الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان مبادره الايجاد من عدمها يعني
بالامس كان الحديث انه في قبول للمبادره
وانه في استعداد من الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان قائد الجيش للقاء
القائد للقوات الدعم الشريعه الجنرال
احمدتي وكان الحديث في جوبا
ولكن اليوم بيان الخارجيه
السودانيه يذهب عكس ذلك ينفي اينيه للجيش
للحوار مع الجنرال ح متي ويقول انه مصير
قوات الدعم السريع هو الاستسلام يعني لا
تفاوض بل الاستسلام حقيقه موقف الجيش
بقياده الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان من
مبادره الايجاد هل توضحت بالنسبه اليك
نعم يعني واضح تماما ان هناك تغيير في
النطق الرسمي باسم الدوله عموما يعني كان
هناك ناطق رسمي باسم الجيش يعبر احيانا عن
البيانات الصادره حول الموقف العسكري
تطورات الاوضاع بصوره مستمره قبل وبعد
الحرب واثناء هذه اثناء الحرب الماضيه لكن
لاحظنا في الايام الاخيره هو ان الصوت
الذي ينطق باسم
السلطه العسكريه وقياده الجيش هو وزاره
الخارجيه في مختلف المحافل الداخليه
وخارجيا بالطبع خارجيا في مجلس الامن
وداخليا هنا في السودان الكثير من
التصريحات تطلع تنظر باسم الناطق الرسمي
باسم وزاره الخارجيه الان واضح ان الناطق
الرسمي باسم وزاره الخارجيه هو يدلي
بتصريحات متفق عليها مع قياده الجيش وبذلك
يمثل الصوره الحقيقيه بمعنى ان النفي ان
يكون هناك فمه مفاوضات في الوقت الراهن
بالطريقه التي ظهرت في وصايا الاعلام هو
الراي الحقيقي للجيش خلافا للاخبار التي
ظهرت قبل ساعات من ذلك والتي كانت تتحدث
عن موافقه
القائد الجيش المفاوضات في العاصمه باطراف
يمثلون الجيش وليس بقياده الجيش الان واضح
تماما والصوره الحقيقيه هي النفي وليس
اثبات هذه المفاوضات باعتبار ان وزاره
الخارجيه الان هي الناطق الرسمي باسم
الحكومه وباسم السلطه العسكريه
طيب
ولكن هل هذا يعني سيد عثمان انه المبادره
الايجاد لن تسلك طريقها
نعم يعني يعني ممكن بصوره ادقه فلنقل انها
حتى الان يعني هي السابقه للاواني بمعنى
ان المبادره ان وجدت بصوره حقيقيه اذا
كانت هناك مبادره ذات اركان حقيقيه
واستوفت كل الشروط انها جاءت قبل الميعاد
جاءت قبل الميلاد فهي لم تولد بعد يعني لا
تزال هناك فرصه ربما لهذه المبادره ان
تاتي مره اخرى بعد التشاور مع طرفين لان
استكمال موافقه الطرفين قبل الاعلان عنها
امر حيوي جدا لضمان نجاح هذه المبادره في
تقديري ان المبادره الان هي جاءت قبل
الميعاد يعني جاءت قبل الميلاد ولن يكون
هناك بالامكان القبول بها طالما ان طرف
واحد يعترض عليه هو الجيش الا اذا استوفت
كل الظروف المناسبه والمهيئه لان يكون
هناك احتمال للنجاحيها طيب ابقى معي استاذ
عثمان ساعود اليك بعد قليل في اخر تطورات
الجهود الدوليه لاحتواء الازمه في السودان
تلقى وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان اتصالا من نظيرته الالمانيه
انالينا بيربوك حول التطورات في السودان
واكد الوزيران اهميه وقف التصعيد العسكري
في السودان وتوفير الحمايه اللازمه
للمدنيين السودانيين والمقيمين على ارضه
وتوفير الممرات الانسانيه الامنه للراغبين
في مغادره الاراضي السودانيه
اعود الى رئيس تحرير صحيفه تيار الاستاذ
عثمان مرغني استاذ عثمان اذا وسط هذه
التطورات
هل يمكن الحديث عن احتماليه تمديد الهدنه
مع العلم ان الهدنه هشه لم يتم الالتزام
بها بشكل كامل هل الامور يعني ترشح
امكانيه تمديد الهدنه ام تعتقد ان الامور
صعبه جدا
لا اعتقد ذلك يعني سيتم تجديد الهدنه
وربما اكثر من مره وفي تقدير هذه هي
المفاوضات الحقيقيه التي تجري الان بمعنى
ان طلبات تاتي طلبات احيان غالبا من بعض
الجهات الخارجيه الاطراف الخارجيه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الامم المتحده
وغيرها
ويتم الاستج
ابه لها
من النص الحديث وليس بالواقع على الارض
لكن هذا يعني عمليا ان هناك نوع من الحوار
ان يكون هناك دعوه
انسانيه ثم توافق الاطراف وبعد ذلك استغرق
هذه الاهدنه ولكنها موجوده نظريا هذا نوع
من الحوار في هذه المرحله المبكره وانا
اتوقع ان يتم تجديد اكثر من مره وربما
تكون هي المدخل بعد ذلك للحديث عن وقفه
اذا وجدت الاطراف التي يمكن ان توفر
الظروف المناسبه لهذه المفاوضات بين
الطرفين لان نوقف اطلاق النار يختلف على
ان هناك الكثير من الشروط التي يجب ان
تلبى ومن الاتفاقات التي يجب ان يوافق
عليها الطرفان بصوره مباشره وصريحه لانها
ترتيبات على الارض وليس مجرد هدنه معلنه
بواسطه الاعلام فهذه النقطه هذه المرحله
مرحله الوصول الى وقت اطلاق نار ستكون هي
وليده هذه الهدن المتكرره رغم ان هذه
الهدن لم تحقق الاهداف المقصوده منها
والياء توفير الحمايه المدنيين والوصول
الى السلع الضروريه والمستشفيات وغير ذلك
لكنها على الاقل
تحقق بين الط
رفين بعد ذلك لمرحله جديده يعلى فيها وقف
اطلاق النار لمده شهر مثلا مضى اطول من
الثلاثه ايام التي دائما تتكرر في الاذن
المختلفه
يعني الم يحن الوقت لجلوس الطرفين على
طاوله المفاوضات كما اقترحت مبادره
الايجاد لماذا لم تنضج الظروف بعد وما هي
الشروط برايي
الامر له يعني حسابات عسكريه محضى هي ليست
حسابات سياسيه هي ليست حسابات متصله
بالواقع الانساني الذي الشعب السوداني
الان وعمليات النزوح الهائله بظروف صعبه
جدا لكثير جدا من المجتمعات السودانيه في
مختلف انحاء السودان حتى المناطق التي لم
لا تدور فيها يعني اشتباكات بصوره مباشره
في الوكره واضح تماما ان المعطيات
العسكريه حسابات التي تبحث داخل الغرفه
المغلقه بين القيادات العسكريه فيها كثير
جدا من التناقص مع الذهاب للمفاوضات وقت
التقمات في هذه المرحله ربما يعني للتخطيط
او في العشر للوصول الى مزيد من التغيير
موازين القوى على الارض تغيير
الوضع العسكري بالنسبه لكل طرف او
التصورات هذا الطرف بانه يمكن ان يغير
الوضع العسكري وبناء عليه يريد ان تقوم
مفاوضات طبعا المفاوضات متفقه عليها انا
اتوقع ان الطرفان موافقان على مبدا
المفاوضات لكن كل طرف يخطط ان يدخل هذه
المفاوضات وهو يحمل عدد من النقاط التي
تسمح له بفرض رؤيته ففي تقدير المساله هي
حسابات عسكريه بحته تقوم على الواقع على
الارض الان وتوازن القوى بين الطرفين من
الخرطوم رئيس تحرير صحيفه التيار عثمان
مرغني شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ عثمان على هذه
المشاركه
ميدانيا غارت مقاتلات تابعه للجيش
السوداني على مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع في
الخرطوم وفي ام درمان
وتصدت قوات الدعم السريع لغارات شنها
طيران الجيش على مواقعها في محيط القياده
العامه والقصر الجمهوري في الخرطوم فيما
سمي عدوي تبادل لاطلاق نار في هذه المناطق
هذا ومشطت قوات الجيش مناطق في محيط مطار
الخرطوم الدولي وفي بحر شمال الخرطوم جددت
الطائرات الحربيه قصفها اهدافا للدعم
السريع في ضحيه كاثور شرقي بحري وقال
الدعم السريع انه رد على الهجوم وتمكن من
احباط هذا الهجوم على المعسكر وكبد الجيش
خسائر كبيره اما فيهم درمان غرب الخرطوم
افادت المعلومات بقصف طيران الجيش منطقه
صالحه
ومناطق قريبه من سوق ليبيا حيث تقع
تمركزات الدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
مبروك مبروك مبروك
مبروك الله
هذا وقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكان واشنطن
تعمل مع الامم المتحده للتوصل لوقف اطلاق
النار في السودان والمساعده في تحقيق
الانتقال الديمقراطي هناك جاء ذلك خلال
لقائه الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
نعمل عن قرب مع الامم المتحده على الازمه
في السودان ونامل ان نتمكن من التوصل لوقف
اطلاق النار ووقف العنف والمساعده في
ارجاع السودان الى مسار الانتقال الى
حكومه المدنيه نتعامل مع وضع انساني صعب
جدا هناك ويتفاقم
ماروسيا فقط دعت هي الاخرى اطراف النزاع
الى ضبط النفس الناطقه باسمي وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخرفه دعت الى
اتخاذ خطوات عاجله لوقف اطلاق النار وقالت
ان الاحداث الماساويه التي يشهدها السودان
تثير قلقا موسكو التي تتخذ كافه الاجراءات
اللازمه لضمان سلامه رعاياها في السودان
وامكانيه تنفيذ اجراءات الاجلاء
هذا وناشد مواطن سوداني طرفي الصراع لوقف
الحرب والاقتتال والعوده الى طاوله الحوار
اناشد السيد البرهان والسيد حميد تبعه
الحرب يا جماعه نسبه لتعب الشعبي
وللمعاناه التي عاناها الشعب السوداني
الذي لم يستحق هذه المعاناه يا جماعه
ارجوكم رد خاص اقعدوا في طاوله بتاعه حوار
وكل خلافات كل لان خلافاتكم شخصيه جماعه
يا جماعه ربنا ده سبحانه وتعالى هيحاسبكم
على ما فعلتوه في الدنيا وفي الاخره
وقف
مواطنين سالمين دارين ياكلوا لقمه الايش
المشكله بقى خطير علينا
ومغليه كل حاجه يعني الناس
المساجين وقراييل الصناعيه للنزل يشتغلوا
اليوم باليوم
[تصفيق]
في كرسي انا داري منكم بس تهزوا
[موسيقى]
ومع احتدام المواجهات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع عبر اهالي في مدينه ام درمان عن
مخاوفهم من استمرار عمليات السلب والنعم
واظهرت لقطات فيديو خاصه بالعربيه مشاهد
تظهر اغلاق المحال التجاريه في الاسواق
الرئيسيه مع اعاده فتح عدد قليل منها فيما
يطالب الاهالي الحكومه بتوفير الحمايه
اللازمه وتامين حياه السكان في ام درمان
ووقفي اعمال العنف
كر
ودرجه ما يوصفون الراعي
واي شارب فيها ناس شغالين شغل مره كسر
الدقائق
كلها مقفله
بعكاكيز جميع السوق يعني الناس قاطعه
الناس حتى في النهايه
يحرسون لكن الوضع سيء سيء للدرجه بعيده
وخلاص في الصوت
قال وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليبر
لان الوضع في السودان قد يتفاقن في الايام
المقبله كما اكد على ان بلاده ستواصل
الدعم للرعايه البريطانيه
وقف اطلاق النار ليس مقدمه بالضروره
للسلام والوضع في السودان من الممكن ان
يتفاقم في الايام المقبله ونحن سنواصل
الدعم للرعايه البريطانيين لذلك نحن
موجودون في بورتودان ولدينا مسؤولون
دبلوماسيون في مصر واثيوبيا والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
قبل ذلك الرعايه البريطانيين في السودان
الى الالتحاق بالرحلات الجويه دون اي
تاخير مشيرا الى ان بريطانيا قد لا تكون
قادره على مواصله عمليات الاجلاء عندما
ينتهي وقف اطلاق النار
هذا وقالت القاهره كما ذكرنا منذ قليل
انها استقبلت سته عشر الف شخص من غير
المصريين عبر المنافذ مع السودان حتى الان
حيث بات معبر ارجين البري الفاصل بين
البلدين بمثابه طوق نجاه الفرين من هذه
الشبكه
معبر ارجين البري يفصل بين الحدود المصريه
والسودانيه افتتح حسب سبتمبر عام 2016
لنقل البضائع والركاب يقع على مسافه 850
كيلومترا شمالي الخرطوم يستوعب سبعه الاف
وخمسمائه مسافر يوميا واكثر من ثلاثمائه
شاحنه بات يمثل طوق نجاه للفرين من
اشتباكات السودان عبر منه الالاف من
السودانيين والمصريين هربا من القتال بعد
اجتياز المعبر يتجه المسافرون الى مدينه
اسوان الوصول اليه يتطلب رحله محفوفه
بالمتاعب تستغرق نصف يوم للوصول اليه من
الخرطوم ومده مماثله للعبور الى اسوان
ونظرا لصعوبه الوضع في السودان سمح
للسودانيين بعبوره بلا تاشيره مسبقه
[موسيقى]
وفيما يتواصل اعلان الهدى في السودان
تتواصلوا عمليات الاجلاء لرعايه الدول من
البلاد لكن هذه العمليه تواجه تحديات
كثيره خصوصا على السودانيين الراغبين في
الهرب من ساحات المواجهه الى مناطق ابعد
او حتى خارج البلاد
تشتد الازمه هناك وتنفرج في المعابر
والموانئ والمطارات لكن قبل الوصول الى بر
الامان ثمه تحديات يجب تخطيها
ولعل الوضع الامني المتردي اخطر تحدي لذا
تشكل الهدن متنفسا للحركه لكن ذلك مرهون
بالتزام طرفي النزاع بوقف اطلاق النار
فمنذ اكثر من عشره ايام اعلن عن اربع هدى
بواسطه دوليه العنوان الابرز لها خروق
وانهيار العائق الثاني في حال تجاوز
الفرينه هشاشه الهدن يتمثل في كلفه التنقل
فثمن تذكره الرحله الى بورتسودان من
الخرطوم في الحافله يصل الى 400 دولار
للشخص الواحد لكن ثمه ازمه اخرى محطات
وقود مغلقه اما الانقطاع الوقود او
الاستهدافها تشهد الاسعار ارتفاعات كبيره
فتكلفه الجالون في السوق السوداء بلغت 50
دولارا اي عشره اضعاف السعر الرسمي
وللتنقل لابد من الدفع هنا مشكله اخرى لا
[موسيقى]
في ظل هذه الخيارات المره والصعبه يختار
البعض المخاطره غير ان اخرين يفضلون
البقاء في منازل ستكون بالنسبه لهم اكثر
امنا من مخاطر رحله قد لا تكون محسوبه
العواقب
كثيرا اصطدم السودانيون بمصطلح الجهه
الثالثه عند محاوله البحث عن المتسبب في
بعض من الاحداث التي مرت على البلاد حيث
كانت مختلف الاطراف ترمي التهمه على هذا
الطرف المجهول واليوم يعود هذا المصطلح
للواجهه فمن هي هذه الجهه الثالثه
المواجهات تتكرر في السودان والمتهم واحد
قبل اسقاط الرئيس السابق عمر البشير قتل
متظاهرون مناوون له عام 2019 والقيت
التهمه على جهه ثالثه بحسب مدير المخابرات
انذاك صلاح عبد الله غوش
انتهى حكم البشير وبعد اشهر من التنازع
السياسي بين المكونين المدني والعسكري حدث
فضه اعتصام القياده ايضا تكرر قتل
المتظاهرين وشماعه التي تلقى عليها التهم
لم تتغير
في وقتنا الحاضر هذه الجهه الثالثه ايضا
هي المتهمه باداره النزاع او الوقوف وراء
النزاع العسكري الدائر وهي قوه او فلول
نظام البشير السابق طرفان نزاع تبادلا
الاتهامات وفي مقابله مع العربيه قال قائد
قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو ان من
يدير الحرب على قواته هم قيادات في حزب
المؤتمر الوطني المنحل حزب الرئيس السابق
عمر البشير واعتبر انهم من يقودون الجيش
رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان رد
ايضا عبر العربيه مشيرا الى ان الجيش
السوداني وكاي جيش في العالم هدفه ضمان
وحده الدوله بشكل عام وليس العمل من اجل
شخص او جهه ما
صريح وهو يعلم تماما انني ليست لدي اي
علاقه بالنظام الساب
ق الجميع يعلم ذلك نحن قوات مسلحه نعمل
بمحترافيه وواجبنا حمايه السودان حتى
معظم هذه الاشاعه يعلم المصداقيه ويعلم
انه انها كلمه باطل اريد فيها
الاتهامات ايضا صدرت من بعض القوى
السياسيه لاتباع النظام السابق بالوقوف
وراء نشوب الحرب واستمرارها ومحاوله
تصعيدها خاصه وان العمليه السياسيه
الحاليه هي التي اقصت حزب المؤتمر
وعلى وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي يتداول
سودانيون ما يفيد بان انصار البشير يرفضون
صراحه قوات الدعم السريع لكنهم في ذات
الوقت يهددون بالوقوف بوجه الجيش حاله
توقف الحرب والهدف واحد مصلحه فلول البشير
حسن جوليد العربيه
لمزيد من المتابعه ينضم الي من لندن الان
مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو مصطفى قبل ان
اسالك عن عمليه الاجراء التي قامت بها
الخارجيه البريطانيه والقوات البريطانيه
ان اسالك بدايه ابرز ما اشتملت عليه كلمه
وزير الخارجيه جيمس كليبر لي امام
البرلمان البريطاني هذا منذ بعض الوقت
خلال هذه الجسد تمت الطرح العديد من
الاسئله واكد وزير الخارجيه لانه يجب على
جميع البريطانيين التوجه الى المطار
العسكري وادي سيدنا لان هناك نافذه يعني
قصيره جدا قبل انتهاء هذه الهدنه وبالتالي
سيكون من الصعب ترتيب اي رحلات اجلاء
لهؤلاء المحاصرين من البريطانيين في الوقت
الراهن
وزير الخارجيه ايضا انتقد لعدم تعامله مع
حامل الجنسيه البريطانيه وايضا اهل هؤلاء
الذين قالوا بانه لن يتركوا سيدان ما لم
يتم مصاحبه ابائهم مثلا هناك الكثير من
السودانيين يعني لديهم الجنسيه المزدوجه
ولا يريدون ترك السودان وطرف ابائهم
بالتحرير خصوصا كبار السن وفي اوضاع يعني
صحيه يعني سيئه لا يمكن ان يتركوهم في هذا
الوقت وبالتالي هناك مناسبه بان تمنح
وزاره الخارجيه والحكومه البريطانيه ممرات
لهؤلاء
لاجلائهم مع اهلهم وبالتالي
قال بان يعني بحسب مكتب رئيس وزراء بان
ليست هناك اي خطه في الوقت الراهن بان يتم
اجناء اهالي حامل الجنسيه البريطانيه ولكن
سيتم مراجعه
الهديه الاجراءات بشكل بشكل مستمر بالطبع
العمليه يعني ربما سيكون هذا هو اليوم
الاخير لاجراء الفيطانيين من السودان ولكن
هناك مساء للضغط المزيد وتمديد فتره
الهدنه بالاضافه الى ان وزاره الدفاع اعطت
تعليماتها للسفينه حربيه بالتوجه الى
بورتسودان يعني بانتظار تعليمات اخرى اذا
ما كان يجب استخدام هذه السفينه لاجلاء
البريطانيين من بورسونان بالطبع
الضغوطات تتزايد على الحكومه البريطانيه
في ظل عدم تعاملها بشكل سريع مثل ما
شاهدنا بالنسبه لفرنسا والمانيا ودول
اوروبيه اخرى ولكن وضع بريطانيا هو مختلف
تماما نظرا لان اعداد البريطانيين في
السودان هم اكبر بكثير حتى الان تم التاكد
بان
بريطاني يعني تم التواصل معهم حتى هذه
اللحظه يعني حتى امس يعني حقيقه تم اجلاء
533 بريطانيا الى قبرص شاهدنا وتابعت بعض
من يعني وصلوا امس الى مطار امس ولكن
يتوقع ان تكون هناك على الاقل ثلاث الى
اربع رحلات قبل انتهاء
الهدنه في ساعه العاشره بتوقيت جرينت
وبالتالي هناك مسائل حديثه الان لتمديد
فتره الهدنه وايضا ايجاد طرق بديله لاجلاء
البريطانيه المحاصرين هناك هل يستشف من
كلمه كليبر منذ بعض الوقت مصطفى ان الامور
ذاهبه في السودان نحو الاسوا وانه من
الصعوبه تمديد الهدنه ام لا لا يمكن قول
ذلك
يعني حقيقه يعني تتوقع الحكومه البريطانيه
المزيد من التدهور اذا لم يتم تمديد فتره
الهدنه وربما هناك بعض الاخبار بانه ربما
هناك امكانيه هذا ما تسعى اليه الحكومه
البريطانيه في ظل الضغوطات التي تواجهه من
قبل عامه الناس وحتى من اولئك الذين
ولو ان بعض يعني وصل اكثر من نصفهم حتى
حتى اجي اللحظه الى الاراضي البريطانيه
لكن يقولون بان ربما هناك بعض التخبط شيئا
ما وخاصه لاولئك الذين مثلا فقدوا اوراق
ثبوتهم واصلتهم بالبلد
العديد من من هؤلاء يعني تواصلوا مع
النائبهم الذي الذي الذين يمثلهم في مجلس
العموم وهناك
شكاوى من هؤلاء النواب لان تتعامل وزاره
الخارجيه
يريدون ان
يصاحبوهم مثلا ابائهم هناك لا يريدون ترك
السودان والحكومه حتى هذه اللحظه لم تبدي
اي استعداد لقبول هكذا طروحات في ظل الوضع
المتوتر وايضا بسبب ان بريطانيا لا يعني
لا توفر اي حمايه عسكريه او فريق من يمكن
ان ان يرافق هؤلاء من مناطق مختلفه الى
هذه المنطقه المطار العسكري في وادي سيدنا
الذي يبعد حوالي 20 كيلومتر شمال الخرطوم
وبالتالي
المسؤولون البريطانيه يتسابقون مع ما تبقى
من فتره هذه الهدنه لاجلال اكبر عدد ممكن
وبالطبع العديد من هؤلاء البريطانيين في
السودان لا يريدون المجيء لاسباب
شخصيه تتعلق بهم ولكن هنا هل هنالك احص
ائيه نهائيه لعدد البريطانيين الذين ما
زالوا في الخرطوم ولا يريدون
ان تتم عمليه اجلائهم هل هنالك اي ارقام
مصطفى
التقديرات تشير الى ان هناك ما يقارب من
4000 مواطني من مواطني المملكه المتحده
والحاصلين على الجنسيه المزدوجه من في
السودان حاليا تم التواصل مع ما يقارن من
2000 شخص فقط وهذا يعني ان البقيه ربما
يعني ربما كانت هناك صعوبات للوصول الى
نصائح وايضا التواصل مع الخارجيه خصوصا
وان هناك فترات يعني تتقطع فيه
الانترنت بالاضافه الى ان حتى خطوط
الاتصال يعني غير يعني دقيقه في بعض
الاحيان خاصه بسبب الاشارات الضعيفه
ويعني
الظروف ليست مناسبه يعني حتى يعني عندما
يتم التنقل من الاخر يجب التواصل مع وزاره
الخارجيه وايضا الوصول الى هذه النقطه نعم
ربما السفر الى الى
القدر من لندن مراسل العربي مصطفى زاهر
شكرا جزيلا لك
ولمتابعه عمليات الاجلاء من السودان الى
العراق ينضم الي من مطار بغداد الدولي
مراسل العربيه سامر الكبيسي الذي يتابع
عمليه الاجلاء سامر اهلا وسهلا بك
كيف تتابع عمليات الاجلاء وابرز مشاهداتك
حتى الساعه عدد الواصلين وهل هنالك رحلات
مجدوله اخرى في الساعات القادمه
في البدايه مساء الخير طالب فعلا وصلت
الجاليه العراقيه قبل قليل الى مطار بغداد
الدولي هناك رحله عسكريه عن طريق طائرتين
عسكريتين خاصه بوزاره الدفاع العراقيه
جلبت 234 مواطنا سته عشر منهم من الجنسيه
السوريه يضاف لهم طبعا العراقيين
المتواجدين ربما هذه هي الرحله الاولى
ستكون هناك رحلات اخرى بحسب مصادر في
وزاره الدفاع العراقيه لكن الطالب اذا
سمحت لي هناك احد الواصلين من الجاليه
العراقيه الى العاصمه بغداد في البدايه
حمد لله على السلامه كيف كانت الرحله وما
هي الاجواء الموجوده الان في السودان
والله حاليا احنا الاجواء طبعا احنا طلعنا
قبل بورد سودان قبل يوم فالحمد لله انه
احنا يعني شبه الاوضاع انه احنا ما نعرف
هناك شنو صار بعدين حاليا احنا الحمد لله
وصلنا ارض الوطن يعني سلامات ومن خلال
قناتكم نشكر الجهود المبذوله من وزاره
الدفاع وزاره الداخليه
الهيئه والسفاره العراقيه الموجوده
بالسوداني يعني
تحت ضغط نفسي جسدي وتعرض اطلاق نار مباشر
والحمد لله انه الامور يعني عدت على خير
ووصلنا احنا هنا كيف كانت الاجواء هل كنت
تسكن في الخرطوم في العاصمه كيف كانت
الاجواء هل هناك اجواء يعني هل هناك مظاهر
عسكريه هل هناك قتال هل شاهدتم اشياء من
هذا القبيل طبعا نحن اثناء الحرب واثناء
الضرب ما ممكن انت شخص تتبادر تظهر قدام
المنافذ يعني لانه متعرض نفسك الخطر كنا
تحت الضغط
النفسي يعني انه ما نعرف احنا بس نسمع
اطلاق نار احنا طبعا وبس يعني ما شفنا
يعني اي جهه انه داخل بس نسمع صوت رصاص
وقذاف ممكن تقع يعني باي مكان من المكان
الموجوده بالسودان هل جميع الجاليه جاءت
في هذه الرحله ام هناك بحسب معرفتكم هل
هناك بعض عراقيين متواجدين في السودان
طبعا انه تبليغ اجى من السفاره انه اي شخص
يود الس انه يسافر للعراق انه حياه الله
يعني فانه اعتقد انه اذا اكو شخص بقى
فبقدراته هو يعني مو وكتب على تعهد يعني
اعتقد انه هو باقي على مسؤوليته بينما انه
الجاليه كلها انه اغلبها وحتشوفون انتم ان
شاء الله الوقت الجاليه العراقيه مواطنين
هناك جراء القصف اعتقد شخص واحد او لا
يذكر واحد او بالسلامه الحمد لله على
سلامتك اذا طالب ربما هذه عينه من الجاليه
العراقيه التي وصلت لكن يبقى التضارب في
عدد الارقام طالب حتى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد
ارقام او احصائيه دقيقه لوزاره الخارجيه
العراقيه لكن رسميا بحسب بياناتها يوجد
نحو 300 مواطن عراقي متواجد في السودان
ربما العدد الاكبر ذهب الى بورت سودان
وبالتالي جاؤوا الى بغداد يضاف الى هذا
كله ربما هناك اربعه او خمسه اشخاص ذهبوا
باتجاه العاصمه الاردنيه عمان اضافه الى
ثلاث او اربع اشخاص ذهبوا الى دول اخرى
ننتظر الاعداد الرسميه من قبل وزاره
الخارجيه بعدد الواصلين والذي يقدر ب 234
16 منهم من الجنسيه السوريه وكما تشاهد من
خلفي طالب هناك مجموعه من المواطنين
العراقيين ياتون شيئا فشيئا من السودان
بعد اشتداد المعارك هناك
تقييم الخارجيه العراقيه سامر عندما تسال
المسؤولين العراقيين هل تقييمهم للاوضاع
انها ستسوء
وان الهدنه لن تمدد وبالتالي هم يحثون
جميع
المواطنين والرعايه العراقيين على
المغادره باسرع وقت ممكن ام لا يعني لا
يوجد مثل هكذا تقييم
طالب ربما هو تصريح غير رسمي لكن عندما
تتحدث الخارجيه عن اجلاء المواطنين
المتواجدين هناك ربما خوفا من اشتداد هذه
المعارك واحتدام ربما القتال ان كان على
مستوى الخرطوم او حتى المحافظات الاخرى لم
يبقى سوى بورت سودان بحسب وزاره الخارجيه
العراقيه بشكل خاص لم يبقى هي المنطقه
الوحيده الامنه التي يتم من خلالها اجراء
مختلف المواطنين ان كانوا على مستوى
العراق او حتى مستوى الدول الاخرى ربما
طائرتين فقط جاءت من السودان تابعه لوزاره
الدفاع العراقيه لكن وزاره الدفاع تتحدث
ربما ستكون هناك طائره اخرى في حال وجود
جزء من الجاليه العراقيه والذين يرمون
الوصول الى بغداد ولم ينجحوا بسبب ربما
القتال او حتى صعوبه الوصول الى بورسودان
لكن على يعني بحسب ما نسمع ممن وصلوا بحسب
نسمع من الجاليه العراقيه المتواجده هناك
في السودان الاوضاع ليست سهله صعبه جدا من
خلال الوصول الى بورت سودان او حتى التنقل
داخل السودان بسبب المعارك والقصف الذي
ربما اغلبه هو قصف عشوائي بحسب ما نسمع
طبعا من الجاليه العراقيه من مطار بغداد
الدولي مراسل العربيه سامر الكبيسي الذي
يتابع وصول الرعايه العراقيين من السودان
شكرا جزيلا لك سامر على كل هذه المتابعه
في جديد التطورات الميدانيه رصد مراسل
العربيه خلو الشوارع في المنطقه الرابطه
بين الخرطوم بحري وانذر بان مع وجود قوات
الدعم الساريه في هذه المنطقه نتابع الان
اقف هنا في صينيه اسماعيل الازهري وهذا
منزل اول رئيس وزراء لحكومه السودان في
هذه المنطقه ليست ببعيده من جسر شمبات
الرابط بين هذا
[ضحك]
الان وليس في بعيده من هذه المنطقه
الطريقه الاخر من هنا يؤدي الى الهيئه
القوميه للاذاعه والتلفزيون التي تتجدد
فيها الاشتباكات في مدينه ام درمان ربما
هذه المنطقه الان كما نراها هادئه لكن
السكان هنا يشكون بالهلع وتوتر بحكم ان
هذه المنطقه بالتحديد يسمع فيها اصوات ذوي
للمدافع الثقيله والخفيفه وفي هذه المنطقه
بالضبط يسمع ايضا مضادات او طائرات بين
الكينه والاخرى اصبحت خاليه تماما من
السكان الا نزرا يسيرا وهم الان يحذروننا
من الوقوف في هذه المنطقه بقناتي العربيه
والحدث سالم الهاشمي من مدينه ام درمان
وفي متابعه الاوضاع الصحيه المترديه قال
المدير الاقليمي لمنظمات الصحه العالميه
لشرق المتوسط الدكتور احمد المنظري ان
الهجمات على البنيه التحتيه الصحيه في
السودان تتصاعد مع سيطره اطراف النزاع على
المستشفيات في الخرطوم وناشد المنظر عبر
تغريده له على تويتر اطراف النزاع للاخلاء
الفوري لجميع المرافق الصحيه وعدم اعاقه
وظائف الصحه العامه الحيويه
تحذير اممي من كارثه صحيه في السودان 24
الف امراه سيلدن دون رعايه صحيه 50 الف
طفل يواجهون مخاطر حقيقيه
احدى وستون في المئه من المنشات الصحيه
مغلقه
16% من المرافق الصحيه تمارس عملها
المراكز المخصصه لمنع تفشي الاوبئه توقفت
عن العمل مع امكانيه وقوع اصابات بسبب شرب
مياه غير صالحه تسجيل 16 هجمه على مراكز
المنظمه الطبيه ومقتل ثمانيه اشخاص
الاستيلاء على مختبر طبي يثير مخاوف من
مخاطر بيولوجيه والتلاعب بالعينات
المخزونه
معي من الخرطوم الدكتوره هويدا محمد الحسن
عضو منظمه اطباء السودان من اجل حقوق
الانسان دكتوره هويدا اهلا وسهلا بك بدايه
لو تعطينا بشكل
موجز اخر صوره او اخر تقييم للاوضاع
الصحيه في السودان عموما وفي الخرطوم
خصوصا تحديدا وضع المشافي
ووضع الصيدليات مع ما يحكى دائما عن شحف
الادويه عن شح في الكادر التمريضي الطبي
تفضلي
مرحبا بقناه العربيه وشكرا لتخصيتها
المستمره
للاوضاع بالسودان انا اتحدث من عن مستشفى
البان جديد الموجوده في شرق النيل
حقيقه او لاول مره منذ 16 يوم يصل الينا
امداد من الطوارئ لاول مره يقلداد
الان وصل الينا امداد في هذه اللحظه من
غرفه الطوارئ
كنا
نلتقي تماما لحتى المشارك يعني حتى احنا
استعملنا الاموات العاديه لفتح
بالعمليات الان لاول مره يصل الينا امداد
من غرفه الطوارئ
الوضع كارثي بالنسبه للاساف يعني الاستاذ
وانا بعثت لكم فيديو قبل قليل حتى الاسعاف
صار يعني يتناقص
من الاطباء اصيبوا بالارهاق والاعياء
ويعني
اصبح مرضى يعني
في
الحالات التي تصل الينا يعني حتى الحالات
حتى غير الرصاص في الحالات اصبحت تصل
الينا حالات امراض
الاطفال الاطفال وصل الينا قبل قليل حاله
ذبحه صدريه وصلت الينا حاله تسمم وصل
الينا على الطفل المتشنج يعني وحتى
الموجود
متخصص للاطفال ولا متخصص في امراض
الباطنيه يعني اخطر الاصابه الموجود هو
يستغراحه يعني حتى احنا
اللون اللي احنا قدمناه لهؤلاء المرضى
يمكن
ولا يكون يعني الان
في عندنا حالات في الكلى وفيها حالات نفس
الشيء وصل الينا بالامس احار السرطان لا
يستطيع البلع تماما وكان عندي جرعات
كيماويه وكان عنده علاجات لا يستطيع
الوصول الى مستشفى
الذره في حديث دكتوره هويدا عن عن بدء
انتشار اوبئه وامراض في الخرطوم في ضوء
انقطاع المياه والكهرباء حديث عن كوليرا
عن ملاريا وانه خصوصا موضوع المختبرات
اللي تم السيطره عليها من قبل بعض
الجماعات المسلحه لو تعطينا فكره هنا ايضا
تم الاطلاع على في قوه عسكريه استولد على
معمل ستارك والان نحن يعني في خوف وقلق
بانتشار او بيئه انا لا ادري لكن بالامس
وصلت الينا حالات لا ادري من السبب وصلت
حالات تسمم وانا لا ادري يعني السبب حقيقه
يعني ولكن
اصبحنا في خ
وف شعر الانتشار الامراض بسبب معمل ساك
طيب
انقطاع المياه والكهرباء دائما في حديث عن
انه
هاتان السلعتان الاساسيتان غير متوفرتان
في المستشفى في المستشفيات هنالك كهرباء
ومياه دكتوره
اليوم ونحن
داخل
والمشكله الكبرى الان ايضا التي تواجهنا
انعدام الوقود يعني حتى انا اظن انني يعني
لا استطيع التحرك
ولا نست
طيع حتى فني التقدير لمنازلهم منه والى
المجلس حتى الذين يسكنون بالغرب من
المستشفى
في خوف وهلع من النهضه المسلح
يعني حتى الحالات التي تصلنا
ج
هاد عليها بغرض السرقه
هل نعم
لا نهايه للوقود يعني
ايضا بالنسبه الينا وانعدام التيار
الكهربائي ايضا لا يوجد
بينجاز لتشغيل المولد
المشفى يعني
بالنسبه الى الصيدليات هل جميع الصيدليات
في الخرطوم مقفله ام لا في صيدليات فتحت
ابوابها
واربحت فارغه
فارغه تماما حتى البقالات
الغريبه من المشفى اصبحت فارغه من الطعام
من الاكل يعني
اليس لديكم اي داله اي اتصالات مع منظمات
دوليه منظمات اغاثيه يمكن ان تمدكم
بالمساعدات بالمواد الاغاثيه دكتوره ام
يعني الامور خصوصا في هذا المجال يعني
لانه بنعرف في السودان في كثير من
المنظمات الاغافيه
اطباء دوليين يعني منظمه اطباء بلا حدود
هل لديكم اي اتصال معهم
التمهيديه لنغابه اطباء السودان عملت عده
مناشدات ونداءات
وكانت الام اس اف واطباء بلا حدود لديهم
دعم لكن كانت صعوبه الوصول الدعم الى
المستشفيات كان في صعوبه لا نطرق كانت غير
امنه لكن حقيقه انا اتعجب للدول الصديقه
ودول الجوار اتعجب كثيرا حقيقه يعني وتعدم
لدول العالم يعني
حتى
يعني كنت اتمنى يعني انه الدول تقي مع
السودان لانه نحن نحترق ونحن نموت يعني
اتعج
ب في يعني
ولم تفكر حتى
ان تبعد الينا بهذه الطائرات ايفل الادويه
المنقذه للحياه يعني
من الخرطومه
الذين يتنازعون هل نحن ما بشر يعني هذا
مجانيات الاخرى
يعني
يعني انا افهم افهم افهم مشاعرك دكتوره
هويدا اامل يعني ان يعني الامور في الايام
المقبله ان يعني تكون نحو الافضل من
الخرطوم الدكتوره هويدا محمد الحسن عضو
منظمه اطباء السودان من اجل حقوق الانسان
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاهده
[تصفيق]
الوضع الصحي ليس المشكله الوحيده التي
تؤرق السودانيين بل هناك مشكله اسعار زادت
من اعباء الحياه المثقله بالفعل فمع نزوح
الالاف الى مدن اخرى ازدادت اسعار السلع
الاساسيه الى اضعاف ما كانت عليه قبل
الحرب في ولايه عده في السودان نتابع
الاسعار
صدمه جديده على السودانيين تزيد الطين بله
نازحون هربوا الى مدن بعيده عن الخرطوم
الالاف هربوا من المعارك الى شبح ارتفاع
الاسعار
ولايه الجزيره على بعد 160 كيلو مترا من
العاصمه ارتفعت فيها الاسعار بنسبه 40 الى
100%
المواد التموينيه ان توفرت ووصلت اضعاف
السعر رغيف الخبز زاد عشره اضعاف مع موجات
النزوح غرف للايجار قدرت بمئه دولار
يباع الوقود على جنبات الطريق ب 80 دولارا
ارتفاع مرعب في الاسعار طال جميع ولايات
السودان
بدل النزاع العسكريه مال ملايين المواطنين
بانتهاء عقود الحصار والفقر والاستبداد في
السودان حيث تسببت المعارك الدائره بين
قوات الدعم السريع والجيش بخسائر اقتصاديه
مباشره فادحه تقدر بمليارات الدولارات مع
خسائر اخرى غير مباشره قد يطول امدها في
حال لم يتوصل الطرفان الى اتفاق قريب لوقف
اطلاق النار
ما ان اطلقت اول رصاصه في مطار الخرطوم
الدولي حتى خسر السودان خمسه في المئه من
اجمالي صادراته ووارداته مليارات دولار من
عائدات صادرات الذهب توقفت هي الاخرى مثل
ما توقفت الحركه التجاريه مع مصر ملايين
الدولارات تتبعثر مع كل قذيفه تفجر مبنى
او تنسف جسرا انها ضريبه الحرب التي
يدفعها المواطنون
المشكله بقى خطيره علينا يا جماعه
المواطنين وعايشين وعايزين
فيها ان لم تهدا المدافع ستدخل البلاد في
فوضى عارمه يحذر الخبراء من مجاعه تطال
الجميع
وحتى ان توقفت الحرب لن يعود التمويل
الدولي بسهوله ولا ثقه المستثمرين ولن
يعود هؤلاء النازحون لدفع عجله التنميه
السودانيه طالما ان بلد الثروات بلا
استقرار سياسي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات